PROFESSOR: Independent events
are events that have nothing
to do with each other.
And needless to say, it's a
lot easier to work with them
because you don't
have to figure out
some weird interaction
between two events that
do have something to
do with each other.
Typical case where
independent events come up
is, for example, you
toss a coin five times,
and then you're about to
toss a coin the sixth time.
Is there any reason
to think that
what the coins did the
first five times is going
to have any
influence on the flip
of the coin for the sixth time?
Well, it's reasonable
to assume not,
which is to say that the
outcome of the sixth toss
is arguably independent
of the outcome of all
the previous tosses.
OK.
Let's look at a
formal definition
now in this short
video of just what
is the technical definition
of independent events.
So what we said is that they
are independent if they have
nothing to do with each other.
What that means is that if
I tell you that B happened,
it doesn't have any effect on
the probability of A. That is,
the probability of A,
given that B happened,
doesn't change the
probability of A at all.
That's it.
Now this is one definition.
Maybe this is the more
intuitive definition.
But another definition that's
equivalent and is standard
is that two events are
equivalent if the product
of their probabilities is
equal to the probability
that they both happen,
that is, the probability
of their intersection.
Now definition one
and definition two
are trivial equivalent,
just using the definition
of conditional probability.
And if you don't see that,
this would be a moment
to stop, get a pencil
and paper, and write down
the three-line proof of the
equivalence of these two
equalities.
In fact, the three-line proof
has this as the first line
and that as the second line.
So you could argue it's
really just the middle line
that you're adding.
OK.
Definition two has the slight
advantage that it always works,
whereas definition
one implicitly
requires that the divisor--
remember probability of A given
B is defined as the probability
of the intersection divided
by the probability B. It's only
defined if the probability of B
is positive.
Whereas the second
definition always works,
so we don't have
to put a proviso
in about the probability
of B being non-zero.
So that's the definition
of independence.
Looking at this definition,
what you can see immediately
is that it's completely
symmetric in A and B.
Since multiplication
is commutative
and intersection is
commutative, which is A
and which is B doesn't matter.
And what that implies then
is that A is independent of B
if and only if B is
independent of A.
Now another fact that holds is
that if the probability of B
happens to be zero,
then vacuously B
is independent of
everything-- even itself.
Which isn't important, but is a
small technicality that's worth
remembering by that definition.
Now again, the intuitive idea
that A and B have nothing
to do with each other is that
A is independent of B means
that A is independent of
whether or not B occurs.
That is to say, if A
is independent of B,
it ought to be independent
of the complement of B.
And that's a lemma that's
also easily proved.
A is independent
of B if and only
if A is independent of
the complement of B.
It's a simple proof using
the difference rule.
And again, I
encourage you to stop
with a piece of
paper and a pencil
and convince yourself that that
follows with a one-line proof.